the pride of Colorado football himself
David bakhtiari how are you David
I'm good little tired coming off
practice but uh doing what are you doing
rich okay so this is this part of the to
a day then practice and the Rich Eisen
show is that what that is yeah I mean
technically this is my this is my tutor
and this is uh okay this means a lot to
me right now
so it's interesting that let's just
start with this because I open my
residual checks that I get every now and
then live on the air
what's your residual check for
pitch-perfect to look like how much what
does that top off at that's funny I
actually just got a I just got a check
in the mail I just opened up okay two
days ago
um 200 and wasn't between the two and
the six - I was after the zero David I
believe so what dummy we we had a
significant part in that film I don't
know if you remember I mean we came on
you know we really helped promote that
David I understand that that in in the
same way that when you when someone goes
in the Hall of Fame you you can't tell
the story of football without that
player you can't tell the story of
Pittsburg pitch-perfect to without you
and your Packer comrades I understand
that David I totally get that absolutely
I mean you you hit the nail on the head
when we had all this tonight it's crazy
I'm the last man in that Wolfpack from
you own with that 2014 watch me no
kidding everyone else everyone else is
either retired or gone or or gone right
you're the last man including clay
that's right yeah you're the last one
David Bakhtiar you've got staying power
man you definitely have Bank power I
think last time I was in your studio I
had a chin strap or know I had a almost
beard no mustache what do you have now
what are we looking at right now gray
hairs I mean come on I'm long in the
tooth you're long so just before we move
on from this subject it is true and I
think we discussed this when you were
here the last time and I want to make
sure you're the one responsible for
getting the Packers on pitch perfect -
because you you were you're the one who
reached out to Elizabeth
banks on twitter correct david that's a
fact well I guess other the millennial
/nz called us wooden or DMS it was funny
I think the husband actually catfished
me remanded if you respond back to me
and then I texted belt them so it was a
very interesting 21st century husband
you did David it's but but that is
unfortunately not caused you to appear
in Charlie's Angels that's coming out
from that producing directing tandem
that's you didn't get in that let me not
that I know of okay house training camp
going otherwise David what's going on
right there in Green Bay
I don't want me through it here what's
it like I mean what you want to know I
got all the time in the world ok let's
go let's go let's go are you riding
bikes are you riding bikes to practice
the team is that we have a select
veteran group who doesn't have to
another officially hit that uh that
eight I told you to get along the tooth
now so you're tapping you tap down the
bike riding you touch the top of your
helmet David I had a my my bike kid been
year back in the day we rode together
for was it four or five years right and
then his last year he ended up texting
me or you either DM me on Instagram just
let me know goes hey I'm not to be able
to make it this year for training camp
I'm finishing up getting a job I'm gonna
be getting ready to go off to college I
was like wait what my bike kids now
going to college
yeah that's long and though he wasn't
when that when that kind of ship sailed
and he was lower than me and I was well
damn I was like you know what it kind of
worked out perfectly the transition to
get on that the shuttles but but
traditions still alive and still well
out here that isn't all I love that
old-school tradition there's no doubt
about it but you have you have moved on
you've grown you're all grown stuff
David I understand David bakhtiari
Packers offensive lineman here on the
Rich Eisen show what is this offense
gonna look like compared to previous
years it's such a burning question
involving the Green Bay Packers for
years and now there's a new coach and a
seemingly new system in town what can
you tell us about it David you know for
what I can say without giving away too
much I think it's going to be a it's
going to be fast and balanced
two biggest things I can say we you know
we put a big emphasis on running the
football and having athletic guys
running around the field from the
offensive line all the way to our
running backs our tight end so you'll be
seeing a lot of bodies just stretching
the field and I think that's going to be
a lot of fun it's going to kind of open
up everything from the play-action to
our our kind of trick replays tour
inside zone so we are still trying to
master it I'm not going to say were
there yet because you know this is what
training camps for but we're definitely
taking each step in the right direction
and I'm pretty excited for to kind of
unveil it and the preseason and
obviously come week one and what about a
kid from last year one of the one of the
young Packers pups from last year that's
making strides that you can see from
your position that you can give us a
heads up who has already taken to either
this offense or just a second year in
the NFL with a year under his belt
David Bakhtiari okay you don't want like
a fantasy pic look at Dark Horse fantasy
actually wanna David just a second-year
guy David that really was my way of
asking that question without directly
asking it so now that you have go for it
what do you got for me okay um I'm going
a Dark Horse late fantasy pick hmm this
one's gonna be kinda a D'Alessio okay
man I got I got to do one stuff it's
kind of splitting hairs don't give me
two really the true dark horse I'm gonna
go Trevor Davis okay okay why is that
the way he plays fit this often is very
well from the current okay it shows okay
that's a good one you know I'm talking
both to Matt Darko it's like you we're
talking out of left field no one knows
and yeah David the everybody essentially
is listening to us right now just
googled him I'm sure you know not not
everybody is well-versed I guess on the
Cal Berkeley bears that are in your
system other than the quarterback so who
else you got you said you needed to sort
of make it listen here you're splitting
hairs I don't really think he's a dark
horse so I can't really say
the running backs will have to probably
this next person I'd probably be a
Marquess Valdez scantling here we go
there's a lot of guys with multiple
names on your offense right now David
you know maybe are you gonna start to be
inspired to go by your middle name as
well what would that yeah I'm you know
I'm trying to teach Marquess to say my
full name so when I address him by
Marquess Valdez Scanlon he'll say hello
David as far as the other side bar sorry
we're I mean so everyone's learning
right now so for him and just take them
a little bit longer but you know he's
just a weak one still we still got some
time for ya give me that one more time
that was that one fast I couldn't write
it down give me that one more time
David a frothy AB asad bakhtiari Wow
that's that wouldn't fit on the back of
your Jersey David I'll be honest with
you no I think it hit the top and then
they have to go underneath the numbers
yeah that's that rare that rare Iranian
Icelandic name that you got working on
David that's uh we haven't that's that's
a rarity right there you know when you
think about him okay um what else do we
got right now so you got that going on
has Aaron had any of the effects shown
any of the effects whatsoever of what
happened that night with you and him
courtside in Milwaukee is that affected
as it rattled his confidence in any way
shape or form
David bakhtiari um I think rattled is
the wrong word I think it's made him
hungry kind of humbled him and there's
you you know made him want to go out
there and kind of prove people wrong you
know and it starts on a football field
so he's got his competitive juices back
he wants everyone know that he's a big
dog and you know he's definitely showing
up when it comes to the competitive
period which I appreciate and that's
what I tried to do in the offseason just
kind of had that field of the fire for
him yeah you know you've got a you've
got to inspire in the way that you can
inspire so is is Aaron like going to the
Gatorade jug or water and just slamming
him now or is he still sipping or what
like walk me through how you've noticed
a difference a change David the biggest
thing when it comes to him
chugging anything is he definitely looks
over both both shoulders make sure I'm
not around us
- you know it's like debo walking
through he doesn't want to let me get
too close you'll start freaking out hand
me he'll just hand me the drink okay
well it makes sense man that makes sense
well I mean you know at whatever works
clearly obviously whatever works and
it's your coach up and about what's
going on with Matt Lafleur is he still
as he still rascal in around what's
happening with your coach Danny he's
he's he's going pretty well pretty
strong when it comes to injury they
they've kind of taught us not to talk
about the people's injuries and players
and coaches so this is kind of a gray
area but I think I'm gonna get in
trouble anyway so I don't care I'm
trying to go into it he's doing well
he's he's walking around he's you know
got off his scooter the Lafleur mobile
which is nice we see it every now and
then he'll take it down to practice but
then I mean he's on his feet he's
walking around he's being really engaged
and that's a testament to his his grit
okay I got very high grit right now for
him to be he's got a boot on one one leg
and he's got this almost like uh you
know a little lifters that short people
using their shoes okay sure or something
like that okay like I rise up to like
lift up the other leg to make sure it's
like a more bounce or doesn't throw off
his hips course it's a crash though okay
you know an insert he's got an insert
he's using inserts
okay it's more like an outer outside and
out cert I like that fantastic
so uh last one for your David and in all
seriousness is it is it different there
does it feel different I mean it cuz
clearly you know when a coach has been
there as long as McCarthy was there's
just a way of doing things and then just
a way that everybody would sense that
things weren't gonna change
I mean talk about a big change clearly
one was made in the middle of last
season does it feel different to you is
there a different sense around your team
right now that you hadn't maybe not felt
in a while entering your seventh season
yeah it's been big I think we went
through a big transition for the last
almost two years with people change
up on the third floor from our GM to
then now that transition trickling down
and obviously with a head coach so now
that whole shift has happened in its
entirety now you really see I mean VB
attitude and the minds of eats even
changed from OTAs to now we really have
understood the culture that coaches for
is instilled and he's really put his
flavor and his twist on how he wants the
Green Bay Packers to look and you know
we're really starting to respond
obviously in beginning your first
exposed to it you don't quite know how
to reflect the image that he wants to
portray right now being around him long
enough you know hearing his messages and
our team meetings seeing that you know
he's all about competition he's all
about competing urgency the team the
ball the north
those are our characteristics that we
have for our football team it's it's
really starting to showing pieces are
really starting to come together so
that's the beautiful thing about
training camp that we're able to really
able to see that come through and I mean
obviously you know we'll really see who
we are the team in the season because
you know they kind of say your true
characters exposed in an adversity yeah
and then the first game two is no joke I
can't wait I can't wait but it's
certainly when they when your team plays
the Bears any time but NFL 100 kick-off
night that's just going to be phenomenal
David I'm assuming you feel the same way
yeah I mean we know we're looking
forward to it and obviously the Bears
are and so does the National Football
League I can't think of the NFL about
the Packers Bears you're right David
Bakhtiari I appreciate the call always
always enjoy catching up with you man
thanks for the call let's let's stay in
touch throughout the season
of course a always a pleasure having me
on you got it
thanks for thanks for thanks for app
thanks for being had it's David Bakhtiar
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app